your smile you've got the fantastic set
of chompers right there you got a great
smile you you really should have seen
them before they were knocked out like
you think they're big now they were
twice the size now you ladies down to
here squirt I heard this your teeth were
knocked out as a child they were yes yes
yes not by a parent or anything
thankfully I lost mine yeah yeah coming
I was an [ __ ] I was I should have
played to baseball practice actually in
the fifth grade and and I had to take a
lap you know and I started off I was
running to centerfield and all I heard
was Walton and I turned around and I
caught a baseball right in my mouth and
literally my two front teeth were on the
ground next to me right yeah what are
they curious if your teeth get knocked
out and they're mature teeth what do
they do like you can't wait for other
ones to grow in what are they doing that
well well no one knew what to do like
literally no one to everybody kind of
freaked out and they they my mother's
boyfriend at the time picked them up
took me to the emergency room and the
only thing I really remember from the
whole experience was the doctor in the
ER talking to a dentist on the phone
saying yeah I have his two teeth no
they're here no I have them in my hand
no no they're not in his mouth I said oh
I have to put them back in his gums
right now wait and they'd they shoved
them up with no novocaine why no
novocaine because of my age I guess I
don't know or just maybe he was at I
just wanted to see me in pain I mean but
if they just literally daddy on time
yeah it's the ball with the glove and
they took the teeth and you've got these
two holes in the front of your face and
they just jam the teeth back they jammed
them back in the medieval era yeah and
and and that and then and in 1979 both
yeah and it in it and it was the most
excruciating pain that I have ever been
in and I woke up the next morning and I
had the blood but they but they took you
know they they actually healed yeah they
healed and they're in the roots
connected and everything was fine until
a year and a half later I drove off the
shallow end into the shallow end of the
pool and hit the bottom of them and
knocked him out again
[Laughter]
and then they were gone then they were
gone and then you didn't deserve them no
but then I had and then I had like
because they couldn't put front
permanent teeth in you know so I had a
like fake teeth like a bridge that I
could literally take my two front teeth
out my entire high school career like
like from that point on and and I would
just kind of take him out to freak out
whatever girl I was dating at the time
put him right on the side but it worked
out that's a way to get the girl it is
[Laughter]
you